foreign
the thing that we have discovered at
Ramsey
30 years ago
that has made all the difference in the
world in people's lives
is not the
tactical what to do with money stuff
it's the understanding that personal
finance is 80 percent Behavior yes
twenty percent had knowledge the
mathematics of becoming a
multi-millionaire
are learned by the sixth grade
spend less than you make
oh Dave
I mean that requires self-control
yeah so the problem is the guy in my
mirror yeah if I can control this goober
he can be skinny and Rich but goober has
a problem his name is Dave
and you know you gotta you guys gotta
figure that out because that's the bad
news the bad news is on the problem the
great news is I'm the solution it's a
decision yeah you just have to decide
you want to do something different
because you kind of already know what to
do we'll give you the fine tuning and
we'll show you the but we don't sell
magic beans here jack is not here yeah
Dave's here
you have to do the work there's no easy
there's no easy button to push on this
there's no magic pill like you said
you're gonna have to look at what you're
doing and if you want a different
situation you're gonna have to do
something different if you want to
experience change you're going to have
to change your habits that's how it
works you can't just keep doing the same
thing and think you're going to get the
same result and what I love about how we
teach money is it is it is they are very
simple Concepts Dave
very simple live on less than you make
yeah get on a written plan and they're
counter-cultural absolutely because most
people spend more than they make yes get
out of debt and stay out of that that's
counter cultural because most people
believe you have to have debt to win and
actually the data says and 30 plus years
of doing this leading more people into
millionaire status than anybody else
tells me and tells you and tells us at
Ramsey that the proper way to do this is
get out of debt because your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income yeah and so you've got to pay a
price to win you've got to live like no
one else so that later you can live and
give like no one else there's a price to
be paid to get out of the mess that you
made yeah and and let us be the like you
said it is counter-cultural because
everything out there is telling you to
be reliant on something else the credit
system is telling you you need credit
you need us you can't exist in this
world without us and the government
tells us the same thing you need us you
can't exist in this world and pay off
your debts you need us everything is
give given us the message that we cannot
be uh Reliant upon our own volition you
know we we can't handle our money
ourselves we can't do anything on our
own and that's completely false you
actually do have control over how you
spend your money you actually do have
control over the decisions that you make
that's false and part of it is whether
you're 25 or whether you're 55 is
growing up absolutely and one definition
of maturity
is the ability to delay pleasure
adults devise a plan and follow it
children
do what feels good yep and I don't care
how old you are if all you do is go on
your feelings
then you're a child absolutely you have
to say all right there's a destination
over here
what has to be true that is not true
today so that I'm that person over there
instead of the person I am right now
come on that you're you are preaching to
the choir right now because some of you
know my story and some of you don't my
husband Sam and I had
half a million dollars in debt for lack
of a better word 460 000 a bit and I
distinctly remember the moment Dave
where I thought if if we don't do
something about this I will never have
any of the things that I wanted out of
life yeah financially with the family I
want to be 20 I want to be 30 pounds
lighter yeah okay good is this a wish
or is this a goal right
if it's a goal
then you say all right when do I want to
be 30 pounds lighter
right when three months from now okay
now we have a goal now then you have to
ask yourself okay what has to be true
that's not true now
and in my case it's less Donuts fat boy
I mean you know get away from the
chocolate donuts boy because the guy
that the guy that's got a six-pack and I
got a keg he's you know he's not doing
the donuts no he's so you gotta you know
okay something has to change and I gotta
like the idea of being thinner more than
I like the instantaneous gratification
and Sugar Rush of a chocolate covered oh
my God I want one donut right well
practically for us it was you don't make
enough money so you need to earn more
money what has to be true that's not
true now I need more money I care too
much about what other people think so
I'm buying stuff I can't afford to
impress these people gotta change that
I'm trying to drag along a spouse who's
not getting going along with this my
spouse keeps running off and doing this
other crap and I'm trying to do this
well what's what has to be true what has
to be true is you guys got to get on the
same page because that's a key data
point in people who win with money they
control their behaviors adults devise a
plan
and follow it children
[Music]
I deserve I deserve a new car call the
wambulance
seriously children do what feels good
now I've been both probably today
but certainly in my life right I mean
there are times there's a higher more
noble Dave and then there are times I
just want one you know don't tell me I
can't do it I deserve it I work hard oh
shut up
like nobody else works hard but you
right I deserve to be deeply in debt and
get a truck I can't afford because they
work hard what you you work hard so you
deserve to be broke I don't understand
how dumb a butt statement is that
but people say stupid butt stuff like
that right it's crazy so you've got to
look out there and say what am I willing
to become so that I am over that person
over there what am I willing to give up
what has to be true that's not true
today we have to be working together we
have to be living on less than we make
we have to be doing a written budget we
have to be cutting up the credit cards
we have to be getting rid of the whole
life policy we're selling a stupid car
we can't afford yeah we're we're not
going on vacation We're not gonna go out
to eat every night we're freaking broke
people we're not doing this anymore and
you start talking to yourself and going
but not for long yeah not for long as
for me and my house we're not going to
live like this we're going to live like
no one else so that later I gotta you
know where I eat out now any dead gun
place I
recommend you now from the left to the
right I don't start with the price I
start with what I freaking want to eat
you know why because I did all this
stuff for the last 30 years and it works
Come On Dave be honest you don't even
have to look to the right
I don't you don't you know you just look
at it the only time I do is on the wine
because some of it's really expensive
but oh man I love it I can go on on and
on about this conversation because it's
true and and the thing is you've gotta
you've gotta find and look inside and
find the reason why if you don't know
why you're not gonna try period you're
going to start and you're gonna go I
heard this guy on the radio Dave and I
heard Jay talking and you get all
excited about it but then when the
rubber meets the road you don't do it
you quit you have to let me tell you
you're gonna get tired yeah and you're
gonna be scared
and you're gonna get dirt on your
fingernails because you work so much
so that later you don't have to yep and
it changes you you know where you want
to be working extra jobs when you're 70
or when you're 27 okay
because social insecurity is not going
to cut it baby
you talk about too much month at the end
of the money broke old people living on
Social Security this ain't fun
once you sign up for a different trip
boys and girls
[Music]
it's all about you the person in your
mirror you can do it we believe in you
and we'll hold you to it